hi this is presh talwicker and in this
video i'm going to explain the five card
reveal trick
so you start out with any five cards
that the audience member picks
what you want to do when you create the
five piles of cards
is alternate between face up and face
down always put the second card face
down
and at the very end
make sure the last card is face down so
that it alternates as well
and then you continue the second pile
the same way
it doesn't matter how many cards you put
in the piles
but if you want to keep it even you know
roughly keep
roughly make four or five pairs of cards
in each of the piles
at this point you also don't want to
make
you want to distract attention from the
fact that you're doing the cards face up
and face down
and the trick here is that
every
card at the end at the top of the pile
is face down
now the person will put their cards
one card on top of each pile
and this is where the trick really
happens
is that you will have two face down
cards in a row
on each of the piles
and when you
mix them up
that will continue to be the same that
there will be
a pair of cards which are face down
as opposed to face up and face down
now when you go through the
rest of the deck
and you either place them the same way
or you flip them over
the only thing that matters is you take
an even number of cards
and this way each pair of face down and
face up cards either gets changed
so that
so just basically so that each pair
one card is face up and face down
except for the cards
where
you had two face down cards in a row
so you can go through the deck
and you can either do two cards you can
do four cards you can do six cards you
can also do eight cards
as long as you make sure you get the
cards to be an even number
it'll be fine when you go through the
deck
and you can do this
over again
it doesn't matter
now when you split the cards into two
different piles
the cards that the person picked will
end up being different from all the
others once you flip over one of the
piles so separate the cards into two
different piles
and now they can flip over either one of
the cards
and what you've done this is really
where the trick takes place is that all
the cards in the deck were face up and
face down in pairs except for the cards
where the person placed them on top of
the other so you had two cards in a row
which were the same
so if the card ended up in this pile
it'll be different from all the other
ones
and the same thing here if the card
ended up in this pile it'll be different
from all the other ones
so we can look through the deck that the
cards which are in the royal flush here
are already face up
and here the cards which are in the
royal flush will already be face down
so either way they flip the cards
you
will see that the cards in the royal
flush will be different from all the
others
and that's how you perform the five card
reveal
you